et près de 500 mille emplois ont été
détruits en france au premier trimestre
une crise qui touche principalement le
secteur privé qui subit une chute de 2
5% une baisse historique sous l'effet du
confinement selon l insee
cet effondrement affecte très fortement
l'emploi intérimaire qui lui s'effondre
de plus de 40% par rapport à fin 2010 9
le ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
affirme qu'il faut s'attendre à ce que
la crise économique entraîne la
suppression de huit cent mille emplois
soit environ 2,8 pour cent de l'emploi
total en france on en parle justement
avec henri sterdyniak et des économistes
à l'oif au restart merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france lors un
deux minutes millions de postes détruits
au premier trimestre qui sont les
salariés a touché par ces à destructions
d'emplois c'est extrêmement simple les
entreprises leur nom d'entreprise à
poncer leurs activités elles ont
maintenu l'emploi des travailleurs
autres à durée indéterminée puisqu'il y
avait le dispositif de chômage partiel
par contre naturellement elles ont pas
renouveler des contrats d'intérim
elles ont pas renouveler les contrats
certains contrats à durée déterminée qui
arrivait à échéance
elles sont naturellement pas embaucher
duchesne est donc naturellement ça c'est
comme ça que tu as une baisse importante
de l'emploi est tout à fait
naturellement
c'est l'intérêt qui est le premier visé
alors bruno le maire anticiper la perte
de 800 mille emplois boiton à s'attendre
à plus
à vrai dire personne ne le sait elle que
tout va dépend de la force de la reprise
est-ce qu'on va récupérer rapidement les
points de pipe que on a perdu
actuellement on pense que bien sûr il va
y avoir une reprise au troisième et
quatrième ce trimestre de l'année mais
que à la fin d'année nous manquera
encore 5% de pib par rapport à la
tendance d'avant crise et naturellement
ça va se
hier par des pertes d'emplois un grand
nombre d'entreprises ne vont pas
embaucher à la rentrée et donc là on
aura d'un côté les intérêts qui vont pas
trouver on aura surtout les jeunes qui
auront du mal à s'insérer sur le marché
du travail
alors quelles sont justement les leviers
dont dispose la france aujourd'hui pour
se relever de cette crise économique
actuelle là plusieurs leviers est
d'accord pour maintenir les aides de
l'état les aides de l'état aux
entreprises et aides de l'état aux
salariés par le chômage
ciel ça c'est tout à fait indispensable
il faut inciter les ménages à consommer
bien sûr beaucoup de ménages ne consomme
pas parce qu'ils ont peur d'aller dans
les magasins parce qu'ils ont envie de
consommer sont perdus envie de consommer
aussi beaucoup parce qu'ils ont peur du
chômage gens qui sont menacés par le
chômage qui se disent mes enfants
trouveront pas d'emploi
donc il faut les aider donc il faut
conserver des liquidités et ça entraîne
un cercle vicieux nord il faudrait que
les gens halde effectivement consommée
il y à certains secteurs le tourisme
l'automobile l'aéronautique l'inflation
qui sont durablement frappé là va nous
falloir penser à des plans de
reconversion parce que dans les années à
venir
naturellement ces secteurs vont perdre
beaucoup d'emplois il faut avancer
d'autres secteurs par exemple la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
c'est un moment j'ai honte de mon aide
on a de la valeur disponibles on peut
emprunter à des taux très bas il faut
relancer des grands projets pour
compenser les pertes inéluctable dans
dans certains secteurs
c'est non effectivement risque de
rentrer dans un cercle dépressif à les
causes du chômage hausse de l'épargné et
on aura le plus grand mal
sortir alors très rapidement vous
parliez des aides de l'état justement il
ya ce prêt garanti par l'état est ce que
c'est une bonne chose ou un risque
justement pour les entreprises déjà
fragilisées de devenir surendettés bien
sûr il va y avoir des entreprises
surendettés c'est à dire qu'il va
falloir dans les mois à venir faire une
sorte de trip de dire bah ya certaines
entreprises elles pourront rembourser
tiens problèmes de trésorerie il ya des
entreprises qui faudra était à dire que
un grand nombre de prêts garantis
devront être transformées en des
subventions on n'a pas le choix
et puis il ya certains secteurs où il
faut dire clairement maintenant désolé
il faut chaud se reconvertir le vous
retrouverez pas le dynamisme que vous
avez eu à voir la crise en raison des
contrats publics en raison de la
diminution des tétées transports il faut
bon il faut jong il dit qu'il faut se
reconvertir et donc à ce moment là il
faut des plans de reconversion dans dans
certains secteurs que ce soit
l'aéronautique l'automobile la finance
la publicité l'événementiel pour
repenser à faut planifier en quelque
sorte à tournant de notre de notre
économie faut pas que les chars à pied
en souffrent donc ou des plans de
reconversion qui leur garantissent au
maintien de leur salaire
mais en même temps dans certains
secteurs il faut bien se dire des vaches
grasses sont finies et il faut changer
de changer d'activité
tardy n'y a qu'à merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste à l'ofce merci d'avoir être
en direct sur arte france